hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's video today is uh
Tuesday September 6th and you know we've
had a very strong sell-off today it is
really the first trading day after the
weekend because Monday was a public
holiday here in the U.S it was uh Labor
Day and you can see this is Monday's
chart you know we had that early close
at noon not really a close but rather
um you know the market goes into a
shutdown until 5 PM
but Market was you know basically in a
kind of a tight range basically between
39.39 and you know 39 20 more or less 20
point range basically going nowhere I
remember on Friday Friday was the
non-farm payrolls right we had that
initial rally and then the big sell-off
okay so we're just basically holding
um you know the last hour of trade on
Friday that range and today Market uh
you know overnight was putting in a nice
move up right it made one two three new
highs I think cash opened and sold off
and what was interesting was the Delta
right I'm coming back to Delta right I
talked about Delta uh yesterday on how
you know I was honestly triggered but
you know that's such a woke term but
it's you know I I say that
tongue-in-cheek where you know somebody
was saying oh I don't know anybody that
uses order flow Delta effectively well
okay maybe you need to widen up your
range of people that you speak to on a
daily basis because I'm about to show
you is very revealing in the Delta right
I mean it was like a sign from above
almost and
8 30 Chicago time cash opens
it is the busiest time of the day in
terms of volume until the cash closed
which would be generally the busiest
time of the day and especially since
Monday was a holiday so everybody has
been waiting for the cash Market to open
since the close of Friday they had to
wait an extra day just because you know
even though Futures were open
um you know it wasn't a normal cast
session to trade
um so when
you're looking at the open Cash open
normally that's when your your heavy
volume is going to appear and what
you're seeing in the five minutes
leading up to the cash open was very uh
foreshadowing of what could potentially
come
during the cast session and what you
started seeing was very heavy selling
five minutes prior to the cash open
excuse me
this bar here big negative Delta minus
1300 next bar minus 588 minus 1294 minus
766 minus 1454.
and then Cash open and we've got a nice
green bar up right so in this one green
bar we pretty much recovered everything
back up to where we were when the
selling started right at the 39.43 and
then the selling continues
so when I was working at JP Morgan right
we would get orders from
you know New York you know they'd pass
us the book to execute orders because
you know being in Asia you've got a lot
of different Futures markets out there
right or in cash markets you'd have Hong
Kong well Japan was handled by Japan the
Japan desk in Japan
are we at Hong Kong with the Hang Seng
uh Korea
that we would deal with
um Taiwan Index right even the Singapore
Nifty on sgx and obviously the uh
Singapore nikai and
a lot of times depending on the size of
the order
the PM would give instructions start
before the cash open right to sort of
minimize the impact
that the order is going to have so when
I see this come in right before
the cash open
it's given me a sign sitting here as a
retail Trader looking at the order flow
that this book is today is really
slanted to the sell side because why why
am I getting all the selling coming in
before the cash open why aren't they
waiting for the Cash open because they
probably got more selling to do once the
cash opens they're trying to feed it
into the market get some done you know
you're talking
and look at this volume three thousand
two and a half thousand two and a half
thousand three thousand so that's
already ten thousand plus another
four thousand so close to fifteen
thousand contracts are trading in the
five minutes before the cash open right
that is
cash session volume already so people
are already coming in selling right
they're getting a head start on their
selling
because they know that they got a lot of
selling to do the Market's going to be
under pressure
all day
and the interesting thing was if you're
watching cumulative Delta it went from
positive to negative obviously pretty
quick because the cumulative Deltas is
small
um you know overnight relative to what
you're going to see during the day but
it went from you know
this bar here plus 4 700 to minus 3400
28 27 1500 767 to negative right when
the cash opens now if you're looking at
a chart like this it might be a little
bit hard to get your head around the
numbers if you're not used to them
that's why I suggest looking at
something like you know a Delta candles
you know on you know different software
providers call them different things but
if you get the Delta numbers put in you
know a candle format it's sometimes it's
a lot easier to see and if you're
looking at the bottom one here is
cumulative Delta I can just see
cumulative Delta dropping from four
thousand to three thousand to two
thousand to one thousand to going
negative crossing the zero line here I
mean that's pretty obvious anytime
cumulative Delta crosses the zero line
you know you obviously know something's
underway but to be honest you know
that's a bit of a lagging indicator you
want to be waiting all day until uh
cumulative Delta crosses the zero line
because you know if
say cumulative Delta is you know minus
10 000 for the day at 11 o'clock and by
you know 130 it reaches zero well that
means you already had a big move up
right so you know don't get too excited
that hey you know what it's crossed the
zero line but you know once you see it
cross you know zero line either positive
or negative you know that there's a move
already underway okay but if you're
looking at the actual individual Deltas
you're seeing these small Deltas coming
in here right I mean 393 is the biggest
Delta positive or negative but
everything else is pretty small you know
see the small candles the numbers you
know the biggest number here is 132 you
got 123 here everything else is double
digits or even single digits you know 11
14 17 44 26. boom minus thirteen hundred
where'd that come from okay well maybe
it's just a one-off big order oh another
588 okay 588 even without this 1300 588
would be considered bigger than 1200.
right then another 766.
and these bars are just under pressure
the entire time you can see the max
Deltas 0 19 0 20 0 okay so you know that
they're strong selling already Market
cash Market opens up
everyone that's had orders you know
sitting on the you know ready to be
executed you know the owl goes to fire
off since you know obviously you know it
was a big
down day on Friday cash Market finally
opens up on on Tuesday there is going to
be some buying you know still people
that are
you know have a chance to buy you know
the first time they you know they had
all weekend to look at their charts and
say Hey you know maybe I should buy
something so I'm not surprised to see a
bit of a jump and then the big selling
comes in again you know minus a thousand
Delta minus twelve hundred you know even
if there is buying here and selling you
know these are pretty evenly matched
until the big sell orders hit the market
here and the market you know sells off
quite nicely just methodically making
new low make a new low make a new low
you get some big pushes here minus a
thousand minus two thousand minus
fourteen hundred keep going down
okay so that's one way you could use
Delta right and it's it's just something
that you could have on your chart
that you can use and you know this other
thing that I like you know after you
know we had this rally here this little
intraday rally what was the sign right
you know you don't want to be buying on
a market that's selling operationally
because you're gonna get your head
handed to you but if you're watching the
Delta you can see it just flip right in
here minus six dollar minus 655 ends up
plus 34. so it went from minus 600 to
positive 34. got a nice little rally
here okay and then something similar
here right the opposite big
6 Plus 660 Max Delta closed at minus 86
as bearish but then it flipped again
right minus 544 closed at only minus 68
and boom
went higher okay so you know Delta is a
fabulous tool you should be adding it
into your trading if you're not already
doing it
um you know I could even talk about all
these buying and balances right coming
in
let's put on a regular chart here it's a
little bit easier to see at the time
but you know you can take advantage of
all these imbalances that are coming in
I mean look at this bar here
it's just littered with buying
imbalances right when you see things
like that you know that the aggressive
Traders are in the market and that's the
way that you should be looking to trade
against right you mean you don't you can
get short in the face of all this
aggressive buying
so
you know again take the pieces of order
flow use them in your trading and you
know eventually it's just gonna
benefit you right you're going to be a
much better Trader and you're going to
have better results right you're not
going to find yourself swimming against
the stream trying to make heads or tails
of what's happening in the market
because you'll be trading on the right
side of the market
so if you like this video be sure to
like it
And subscribe to my channel you know so
anytime I post a new video on order flow
you'll get a notification
so again everyone thanks for taking the
time out to watch this video and
happy trading bye-bye